hi I'm probably the only Dutchman he
knows so that's yeah I promise I won't
set fire to the theater at least I'll
try not to
so my name is Nils you may know me from
a website called html5 tests and I am a
Muslim attack speaker I'm a Google
developer expert and Microsoft MVP which
10 years ago would be kind of awkward to
say at a conference like this I tweeted
html5 test and I have to admit one thing
beforehand unlike my impressive flaming
code skills I I actually kind of suck at
drawing and as you will see throughout
this talk and I'm very sorry about that
upfront so now I love the web I've been
a web developer since 1994 and I've
written my first HTML 25 years ago yes
I'm I'm old
I love HTML I love CSS and I've even
grown to love JavaScript and I love
electronics so when I was a teenager I
had this cardboard electronics kit with
all kinds of different components and it
had wires and you could connect them
together with clipping the wires between
little Springs and you could create a
radio or you could create a transmitter
from Morse code and yeah this is my
drawing skills this is pretty awful this
is what I have now
still some components to connect
together with some wires but the
components have become much more
advanced instead of micro of instead of
transistors and diodes and resistors we
now play with microcontrollers and all
kinds of sensors and everything works
together now I know some of you are
thinking why should I care about
yes I am a web developer I don't have
anything to do with electronics and
you're probably right
but when you connect devices to the web
like electronic devices that you make
yourself you get the Internet of Things
and you get devices the talk to servers
or even directly to browsers and there
things are starting to get interesting
for web developers so first of all
having a little bit of knowledge about
IOT and connected devices is very useful
because these kinds of devices will only
become more pervasive and there's a good
chance that you will encounter this in
your day job in the future
well maybe not programming devices but
building apps and interfaces that talk
to devices the technologies like web USB
and web Bluetooth are being rolled out
to browsers and it makes sense for us to
get to know this but it is also
extremely interesting because there's a
lot of engineering directed towards
connected devices this is where
technology loss technological innovation
happens extremely fast if you want to
know about cutting-edge stuff this is
the place to be
and the most important part it's also a
lot of fun to play with this technology
even if you will never use this in your
day job it's just an amazing experience
to let's say build an web app that talks
to a microcontroller to drive around a
toy car now the main issue I've seen
when web developers start playing with
microcontrollers and IOT is the barrier
of having to learn C now C in JavaScript
yeah but JavaScript may look quite
similar syntactically but it is a
completely different beast you not only
need to learn C but also low-level
programming concepts like memory
management's pointers and even though I
learned this way back in school
25 years ago I am a dinosaur
I hate this what if we could use a
language that we already know what if we
did not need to worry about those
low-level concepts what if he could use
JavaScript on microcontrollers and not
only that what if we could leverage the
browser to connect these
microcontrollers and let them extend
each other's capabilities now this is
all fine and well but microcontrollers
are slow they are really slow
now when I say slow that really does not
convey the idea of how slow you actually
are they are slow so take for example
the slowest computer you can buy today
the recipe pie this is the 0w and it is
slow so rest already
rescue pies are slow but this is the
slowest they make and it's still a great
little computer it runs Linux nodejs
and runs a full browser like Chrome or
Firefox but this is a computer this is
not a microcontroller this is a micro
bit it's a little board created for
schoolchildren and runs just at 16
megahertz it has only 16 kilobytes of
RAM
sorry max TB bytes keep it bites of RAM
it is slow but it's not even by far the
slowest microcontroller you can find but
it is fast enough to run JavaScript now
comparing to the Raspberry Pi and that's
about 60 times faster it has way more
memory - so the micro bit is on a
completely different level now when I
started working with computers 32 years
ago back in 1987 I know I'm old
we had an Apple Mac plus and it was a
fantastic computer back at the time and
I learned programming on it and it was
pretty slow even back then I still loved
it it booted up from a floppy disk and
after a couple of minutes you could
remove the operating system floppy and
an insert an application floppy and then
start the application then after a
couple of minutes whenever the app
needed something from the operating
system that wasn't already loading in
memory you had to swap the floppies
again and all the while while you used
the app now eject the app floppy into
the OS floppy and vice versa again it
was awful
and fantastic at the same time now this
is 30 years later this studio computer
is probably more advanced than most
microcontrollers it's probably just as
fast as a microbe it's definitely more
memory it had a whopping one maybe bytes
of RAM and here we are 30 years later
and we're going to run JavaScript and
something that is less advanced than
this this thing so are you crazy
well two years ago when I started
playing with microcontrollers I would
have said yes there are however very
good reasons for running JavaScript on
microcontrollers is brilliant first of
all javascript is easy compared to C
compared to C two years ago I created
the gadgets for showing notifications
from my home automation system on an 8
by 8 pixel LED screen so whenever I get
mail you know the physical kind of meal
actual letters in my physical mailbox it
shows me a little icon of a mailbox so I
can go outside and fetch it so this is
an impression of me getting meal and
this is the pixel display it's actually
ceiling lights that I improved it shows
a little icon of a mailbox and I wrote
see and it took me eight hundred and
seventy seven lines of code that's
excluding all kinds of libraries I had
to use and we are going to create this
project in JavaScript today and it's
going to take us less than 30 lines of
code that is what sold me on JavaScript
on microcontrollers now microcontrollers
are very power efficient I can in
JavaScript on tiny little Bluetooth
enabled boards and power it using a coin
cell battery and it can run for months
so slow is a good thing because when we
make things faster they require more
power and microcontrollers are fast
enough yes they are slow but we only
have to solve very small problems so
microcontrollers are fast enough for
everything I'm gonna show you today and
finally they do not need an operating
system as it's not in a traditional
sense so that may sound bad but it's
actually fantastic because when I flick
a light switch I do not want my Linux
powered lamb to take 45 seconds to turn
the lights on yeah
so how can we do this so let's take a
look how we can get JavaScript on
microcontrollers so the lots of
different projects in various stages of
maturity and supporting different types
of microcontrollers
and we're gonna focus on s Perino it's
an open source project
you can also buy hardware with s Perini
already installed so it's plug-and-play
but there are also versions you can
actually flash yourself on your own
hardware and it's an interpreter that
supports most of JavaScript even some
es6 features like arrow function so and
it has a ripple functionality that means
that if you connect it to a computer
like using a USB cable or using
bluetooth you can run JavaScript code on
it just like you would in the console of
a browser now it supports multiple types
of microcontrollers like the ones based
on the ESP chipset from expressive so
this is basically just a Wi-Fi chipset
that has a small micro controller and
was originally intended to add Wi-Fi
capabilities to existing
microcontrollers like an Arduino but in
its own right it's also a very powerful
microcontroller now the most famous
example is that of an ESP based
microcontroller is a note M hue now
there are many cheap microcontrollers
boards that you can buy for a few euros
on side like Aliexpress or in your local
electronics store and you're the chipset
is the Nordic NRF 52 so these are a
little bit more expensive than ESP
ranging from 15 to 40 euros so there are
some options like a purchase which is
basically a small button with a coin
cell battery or pixel D S which has a
screen can program little games on it
like the offline dinosaurs game this is
Arduino pin compatible so you can use
all kinds of shields like motor
controllers and that is exactly what I
used in one of the demos this is the
micro bit again I would not recommend
using this for except maybe the most
basic projects and finally the Nordic
thing and this is a device created by
the same company in Nordic and it has an
amazing amount of sensors buttons and
LED rechargeable battery and you can use
all of that from aspra we know and I
brought some of them with me
so after this talk if you'd like to play
start playing with microcontrollers I
can give a few away just limited memory
but come up to me and I might have one
left so now it's time for the demos this
is the fun part of the talk I hope for
me it's not so much fun because I'm
actually pretty nervous because we had
some demos so far
during this conference they all worked
so my is destined to fill I do have some
warnings to give because this is
cutting-edge stuff awkward demos with
experimental Technic technology and most
of it is using Bluetooth which is
wireless connection I'm good as uses the
same frequency as Wi-Fi and this room is
full filled with Wi-Fi devices so this
is my at the moment where my heart rates
goes through the roof actually last year
I was in a little car accident and I was
wearing a heart rate monitor and I was
also wearing a heart rate monitor during
one of my talks and this is about car
accident this is just before I give a
demo so yeah so let's get on with it
the first example a connected light bulb
so to create this we need some LEDs this
is a neopixel ring it has 24
individually addressable LEDs so you can
change the color of each of these LEDs
to a certain color you need wires three
of them power grounds and one for the
data and you need a microcontroller this
is an USB 32 base note MCU so I brought
that with me
so let's see if this works yes
this is it now when I connect this to my
computer it does nothing don't worry
that's what I expected to happen
this is not a failure this is yeah
so let's program this first we're gonna
need a color RGB this ff99 0 0 this is
orange and we need a buffer to put those
RGB values for very reason so we need a
buffer of 24 RGB values and now we need
to fill that buffer using a loop and
we're gonna set an RGB value to each of
these LEDs in the buffer now you notice
that is for slightly unusual order for
the RGB here GRB that is because the
neopixel yeah works like that now we
have our buffer full of RGB values and
then we need to use a library and use
that to write that buffer to the D 15
pin and that is the pin on which the
data cable is connected now let's
actually connect to the device and
upload
[Applause]
so this is it um so thank you for your
time I can do a little bit more with it
yeah yeah so let's replace this with a
mathematical function let's create a
gradient from blue to red upload it and
it works so you can figure out yourself
you can basically use it to do anything
well okay change colors not anything
change colors let's make it a little bit
more complicated I'm gonna use a an
interval at 16 milliseconds and I'm
gonna write some make some pixels red
make some pixels blue I'm gonna rotate
it around it axis upload and we have an
alarm
[Applause]
[Applause]
now let's let's do a little bit more
let's get rid of this and go back to our
original example and make it orange
again it's boring make it easier to use
instead of doing this in line make it a
function call the update function it
doesn't change anything it's still
orange it's orange but now we have a
function and we can change the value of
the color and call update and it should
get a new color let's use Bluetooth so
we're going to advertise our device as
an esper we know light we're gonna offer
some services in characteristics make
that writable and readable and the value
of that characteristic is our RGB color
in three bytes and if somebody writes to
that characteristics we're going to use
the bytes that we get and assign it to
our color and call update now I can do
it like this but I also brought
something with me just connect that one
this is basically the same thing except
I build it in a light bulb I'll connect
that and it's supposed to be orange II
not really visible and it's disliked but
um well that's now thank you let's go to
a browser so I can use a browser to
connect to this device using the web
Bluetooth API and to do that I need to
call navigator Bluetooth dot request
device and specify the name of the
device like
Espino lights and offer an optional
services array with the service I
defined in the device so if I execute
this dialog will pop up and I can
connect to the light
it found okay
next we're gonna need to open a
connection to the GATT server on the
device done we're gonna get our service
done and we're gonna get our
characteristic now this is four lines of
code I can now call the right value
function on the characteristic and send
over three bytes like FF 0 0 80 this is
pink
[Applause]
I can do some more examples I can make
it red or green just five lines of code
in a browser and less than 30 lines of
code on the microcontroller and we have
an IOT connector light bulb I can
quickly show you something else I can
connect you to some light bulb using a
web app it's basically calling the same
five lines of code
[Applause]
but I can also do something else like I
said we can extend the each other's
capabilities so we can use CSS
animations on this thing it's not really
fair because it's running in the browser
[Applause]
and now it's turned black yeah so this
is fun this is fun but we can do so much
more
so let's get this out of the way and I
have here the LED pixel display I'm
going to try the cables are a bit short
drop it
and let's get rid of this connect to the
device there is and we're gonna write
some code so first again we need a
buffer
this time it's 8x8 by RGB we need a
function to draw so we have a position
that's from the top left to the bottom
right and we have an RGB value we're
gonna set that RGB value again in the
buffer in a certain position I'm gonna
write that to the d4 pin in this case
now to clear the screen
I'm just filling the buffer with zeros
let's make it black and just like the
light bulb we're gonna advertise it
using using Bluetooth and we're gonna
make it right a bowl and in case the
first byte is a zero we're gonna clear
the screen and if the first byte is with
one we're gonna draw in the second byte
it and the position the third fourth and
fifth RGB so this is less than 30 lines
of code so let's upload and save this
fresh this on the device itself and I'm
gonna disconnect
and I have a different demo here I'm
gonna connect to it
this is always a tricky part is the
device actually showing up yes thank you
so let's pair and I'm gonna do I'm gonna
write I'm gonna draw a self-portraits
is actually working so
thirty lines of code they did I think
this is amazing now I do have one more
thing
but this terrified me but the next thing
is actually is way worse
this is I brought a car with me
it's a Lego car not a real car but still
I'll go back here for a bit
we had the pixel display the
remote-controlled car this is just a
lego car and I added a arduino motor
shield and the pixel das and well they
snap together I built some Lego to
connect it to the car and then it should
start driving
well after I program it um so let's turn
this thing on and get rid of this
now I should wait for the car to appear
and not do this on the pixel display
because that don't make sense so to
drive well we need a function called
drive I'll explain later
now this function this this calls or
writes certain values to certain data
pins and those pins are determined by
the motor boards so the D 12 and D 13
pin is basically making sure the motor
turns clockwise or anti-clockwise and
you'll notice here one left motor is low
high and this is high low this is
reversed that's because the motor the
motor is turned 180 degrees so and the
next one of the three in the eleven that
is the power we're going to use full
power I'm not gonna bother with slow
cars we need a function to stop this is
very important because so we just gonna
set the power to zero and then we'll
stop this is getting scary next
functions forward reverse left and right
so basically forward is both motors full
power reverse is well reverse is
basically the other way around
and left is one motor forward in the
other backwards this is something with
the lights here yes
I'll upload this alright now this is
very tricky because I have to type and
at the same time try to prevent this
thing from falling off this table so
we're gonna turn left turn right and
stop so this worked so let's make this a
remote-controlled car we're gonna add
some Bluetooth code again advertise its
characteristic services you've heard her
this before and we're going to look at
one bite we're gonna send one by to this
thing and depending on what the value of
the bug is we're going to go forward
left right reverse or stop now
the values of these bites are are a
double USD which is kind of like arrow
keys let's upload this save it and now
I'm actually going to put this on the
ground just connect
wait-wait-wait-wait-wait now it will be
really ambassador embarrassing if I now
crash the car and destroy the flag but
I'll try not you so let's try this
[Applause]
I can see I have just a minute or two
left now I'm gonna perform a very daring
stunt I'm gonna try to not crash this
car while steering it from this table
straight into the audience and I have
just one shot so if I feel I'm yeah I'm
gonna have to buy a new car for my
four-year-old son yeah okay
[Music]
the reason it was kind of itchy a few
minutes ago was that it actually it
contains a lidar sensor laser
range-finding sensor I can use that to
measure distance so I'm gonna measure
and if the distance is over a certain
threshold we have an emergency mode it's
gonna go full reverse
and once it's it's clear again once it's
on safe grounds you're gonna stop
hopefully
so this worked at home about 75% of the
time I must not forget to actually
initialize library and start using an
interval to measure measure measure
because otherwise it just right up load
gonna save it done I'm gonna disconnect
now a very important part that I learned
early on now I have to power cycle
because otherwise there we go and now it
should work I hope
let's connect again
[Applause]
I am NOT going to try again
I'm already way too lucky yeah so well I
hope you enjoyed this I hope you can see
the potentials of this technology and
like I said if you're interested in this
power switch if you're interested
interested in this I have a couple of
the thingy 52s with me so come up to me
after or during the break and I might
have one for you thank you
[Applause]